NARRATOR: According to NASA,
the colonization of Mars
will begin not with
humans, but with robots
sent ahead to
construct habitats,
rovers, and life support units.
Food and supplies
will be sent next,
and then, finally,
the first humans
will arrive, ready to start
their new lives as Martians.
FEMALE SPEAKER: The
Martian environment
is very different to earth.
It has 38% of the
gravity of earth.
The daily temperature
fluctuations are very extreme.
For instance, if you're near
the equator on a summer day,
it can be as warm as
70 degrees Fahrenheit.
But at night, the temperatures
could drop down to minus 100
degrees Fahrenheit.
So there's a lot
of things out there
that's getting us,
including radiation as well,
and the dust storms.
PAUL DAVIES: The atmosphere
is incredibly thin, about 1%
that of Earth.
There's no breathable
oxygen there.
The radiation is
very high as well.
And so, astronauts
there are faced
with multiple difficulties.
A Martian day is
almost like earth's.
It's 24 hours and 39 minutes,
so it's just a little
bit longer than a day on earth.
But a Martian year is two
years, because Mars' orbit
is twice the size of Earth's.
NARRATOR: Because of
the day/night cycle
and the thin atmosphere, Mars
is the only nearby planet where
large scale greenhouses
lit by natural sunlight
can be utilized.
These structures will
allow the colonizers
to grow their own food on
the cold and barren planet.
Obviously, you can't
rely on food parcels
from home coming
every two years.
You're going to have
to grow your own food.
A lot of people think, well,
that's pretty straightforward.
You just take a few potatoes
and cabbages, and away you go.
You can do farming on Mars.
Well now, research that's
been done at Arizona State
University suggests
that when you
send microorganisms into
space, they behave differently.
They don't like it up there.
Hundreds if not thousands of
PhD theses in the last 20 years
have been written about
how to grow food on Mars.
And there was a very
interesting experiment
done a couple of
years ago in Holland,
where NASA provided
the Dutch with what
they thought was almost
an identical copy
of the soil of Mars.
And the Dutch
planted 4,200 seeds
in it of all kinds of
different vegetables,
and every single
seed germinated.
Some things did better
than others, like carrots
grew very well there.
There is no question that
we will be able to grow food
on Mars, but it's going
to be hundreds of years
before we grow enough
food on Mars that we can
survive from the food we grow.
The only way we're going
to be able to do that
is to terraform the planet
so that it becomes much more
earth-like so that
we can grow crops
on the surface of the planet.
NARRATOR: In recent
years, scientists
have proposed various
methods to terraform Mars,
deliberately altering it
to be more earth-like.
Most focus on melting
the ice at the poles
to release carbon dioxide into
the atmosphere to thicken it.
MALE SPEAKER: If we heat
up the poles on Mars,
that causes a significant
temperature rise on Mars,
and we start having
flowing water on Mars,
especially around the equator.
Then water itself will go
into the atmosphere, which
is another greenhouse gas,
and we will warm up Mars,
and we will be able to plant
crops on the surface of Mars.
But that's a ways away.
That's probably at
least 300 years away.